pour l'instant on va parler des stars
justement est-ce que c'est difficile de
vieillir quand on est une star and pas
parce que beaucoup beaucoup de
changements physiques et vous allez voir
que c'est assez assez assez
impressionnant il est prise de poids les
rides les aléas de la vie enfin surtout
chez les américains où on va dire mettre
très honnête très souvent ils sont comme
ça et puis côté à un film qui arrive up
beaucoup de muscu parfois un petit peu
de ils sont un petit peu bien qu'il soit
un petit peu aidés et surtout gaulle et
pour un film dont vous allez voir quand
même je vais vous montrer quelques
quelques photos alors justement russell
crowe regardez ça va arriver
alors on les a pris de court la
bogoss et le avoir après à chaque fois
là pour qu'on active un petit peu voilà
évidemment il hilary entre temps mais
j'avoue que c'est un petit peu plus dur
mickey rourke évidemment je n'ai pas de
trop on en parlera après voilà un mickey
rourke était six
mois ça mais que basile bazire bordelais
voilà
c'est un peu dur alors dit kamel agents
chimiques a nnoncé dicaprio évidemment
dicaprio c'est un peu dur aussi
moi j'y vais sans problème et bien les
clients d'hier on dira alors on n'a pas
su ouvrir quelques est-ce qu'on peut
directement à meg ryan forcément bon
malgré une solide avance et ses katas
c'est un peu difficile voilà si on peut
voilà c'était soit la dengue rayonne
c'est très compliqué
maintenant
et alors je passais une dernier essai
pour le coup c'est une française et
j'aime énormément et elle est là parlait
aussi la chirurgie esthétique donc c'est
emmanuelle béart
ici et c'est une femme que voilà que
j'adore mais c'est donc voilà forcément
on s'est posé la question est-ce que
c'est difficile de vieillir est ce que
forcément il faut passer par chirurgie
esthétique est ce que c'est les prises
de poids est ce que c'est enfin voila
quand on est un acteur mieux quand on
fait de la télé tout ça comment est ce
qu'on s'est finalement hugo tout dépend
ce sur quoi on mise à la base c'est vrai
que si notre carrière démarre sur le
physique ont un rôle où on est glamour
on est sexy et qu'après on surf dessus
pendant des années on va essayer de s'y
raccrocher pendant des années donc
malheureusement passé par parfois des
séquences bistouri qui sont pas toujours
très réussi et après quand on misé sur
le talent comme certains le font ils
vieillissent fanny ardant elle a pas
voilà elle a fait une carrière qui a
duré
comment tom ang / louis gérard depardieu
bon lycée nous voilà il a trouvé des
rôles qui correspondent à son physique
et voilà donc je parle pas d'accord je
lève le doigt trois lames c'est
formidable de ta vie tu des disciplines
et je vais toujours été à jeter oui
merci je suis pas d'accord avec ce que
dit hugo parce que effectivement quand
tu tu prends un exemple tels que gérard
jugnot il n'a jamais été super beau
gosse et l'aura du pardon de laideur
gens me demandaient où la batterie tout
le monde s'est elle pas c'est vrai il
était pas et c'est un beau gosse
c'est magnifique
mais au-delà de ça je pense que à
hollywood et surtout avec les lois
d'aujourd'hui pardon mais mère nature et
instagram ne nous donne pas le le choix
de vieillir il est interdit de vieillir
et qu'on ait du talent qu'on est pas
talent on ne peut que perdurer que quand
gagner une gueule mais meryl streep elle
est sublime et elle l a pas fait trop
baby elle a parié sur autre chose au
moins est ce qui fait que sa valeur et
sa gueule tu vas ce que je vais dire
aujourd'hui le pas besoin pas miser que
sur le fil la société nous dit que
vieillir c'est mal en fait on en a plus
le droit pénal même si tu mise pas sur
le tabac sur le physique ça n'empêche
que ça peut être compliqué de vieillir
dans la peau d'une femme même d'un homme
de voir qui allait il pouvoir comprendre
bien sûr de voir que la jeunesse arrive
donc on ya des rôles qui nous sont moins
proposer ou alors même qu'on a du mal à
se renouveler je pense que même si tu
mise pas sur ton physique
psychologiquement mais même là la télé
on va être honnête franchement alive sur
quelle chaîne à ce que jamais de la vie
je dirais qui met un patron de chaîne
qui m'avait dit une chroniqueuse passé
30 ans n'a rien à faire à la tester ça
mais voilà quoi bah
moi je trouve ça agaçant qu'on parle
tout le temps du physique des gens enfin
surtout des femmes quand elles font ont
dit oui mais les belles comme jennifer
lopez mais elle a fait çà çà çà çà ça
dérange quand elles font rien oui mais
elle se laisse aller en fait elles sont
nées toujours dans la critique elle se
font toujours critiquer si elle délice
trop bien elles se font critiquer si
elles vieillissent trop mal elle sourit
ticket donc on peut maintenant ce qu'on
arrête de parler du physique des gens
s'ils ont du talent et reste s'ils sont
pas de talent ils partent oui c'est mon
choix et mais il est vrai méchant pièces
de gamme c'est dans la presse people
c'est exactement ce que j'avais un coup
j'assume c'est vrai que
les avants après typiquement les matchs
où périt macaulay culkin ah les cons
vraiment morflé c'est vrai qu'on se
régale un petit peu et mais c'est jamais
méchant et l'épisode de owens ouais vous
à tous retrouvés c'est ce qui a choqué
la loge qui sont tous dans un état de
deux
sorties sur la photo
ils ont été gentils ça c'est vrai c'est
très dur alors forcément comme vous
moquer des autres se moquent un petit
peu de vous puisque l'on retrouvait les
photos des chroniqueurs plus jeunes vous
allez voir c'est quelque chose je ne
sais même pas partie on commence par ce
que j'ai dans la main c'est ça ça fait
très mal
[Applaudissements]
jacques une sublime sublime c'est l'état
qui sublime la hawala
manninen
tout jeune ado j'étais très jeune enfin
j'ai plus que maintenant je suis
aujourd'hui aujourd'hui j'ai quarante
désormais bel et non la réflexion sur la
chronique à
l'antenne après il apprend bien dans la
gueule
sur 7 je n'allais pas pareil daniel
moreau
[Applaudissements]
couderc
benhaim cette chaîne quand même plutôt
sympa le suivant alors le jour c'est qu'
aux mondieux
[Applaudissements]
gérer bouffées de chaleur
météo quand même voilà j'étais beau
garçon c'est possible mais on ne maigrit
qui ont quand même quand tu étais beau
quand même il était beau gosse si
le matin il a fait un super boulot c'est
quoi un très beau glos a clos à vous
savez ce que c'est qu'un globe
s'est passé c'est la fable ou de
démarrer une carrière à la hugo man au
fait vous êtes mes shows
générique de en fait ça c'est à l'époque
delà du monde 98 et c'est la mode donc
je relève la tête et j'avoue j'en ai
repensé et malheureusement
dix où il a un côté gilles et enfin
c'est vrai c'est vrai c'est vrai a battu
mais on veut arriver à toi dans un
instant à l'autre suivant j'ai halluciné
ouais j'ai toujours
vécu là il ya 18 ans avec la fuego
modèle c'est génial tu avais dit céline
honda oui j'avais 18 ans
très beau gosse aujourd'hui mais tt il a
surtout pris le le blouson du ne sont
pas à mon avis nous ont
laissés à leur sort sur les photos bien
sûr qu'ils avaient prise en photo il y
avait un concours de jeunes mannequins
dans un accident il n'existe plus que
s'appeler magazine 20 ans qui la gagne
elle a envoyé au magazine matin j'étais
sélectionné je suis parti à paris pour
la sélection faut faire mannequinat un
tel degré jamais été pris parce que leur
antre le entre epinal j'ai habité et
paris j'aime le plus c'est d'acné je
suis arrivé c'est une
catastrophe pour renvoyer chez moi
direct tout ça s'est passé à sac tu es
une carrière
mais j'ai toujours le bal ma mère atx
maxime bateau avec moi l'intérieur les
finalistes du concours est l'une des
très beaux encore aujourd'hui
jean-michel gentil s'entendait très très
beau fun n'en faites pas trop non plus
ah non il est beau gosse franchement il
est beau gosse nomme
alors le suivant il ya plein de mecs
quand ils sont moyennement bon
deviennent un peu plus beaux ils sont
eux qui
n'ont pas ce que regardent
westergaard
[Applaudissements]
bonne tasse sébastien folin
avec l âge et avec l âge j'avais 25 dons
enfin non ouais bah oui bon c'est fou on
était pas mal tepa maltais par allait
forcément le dernier alors là vous allez
halluciner ce que vous allez voir qu'en
fait il fait vraiment faire partie de la
famille hanouna regardez la photo la cvo
de famille alors même timide non ici là
c'est papa de cyril ouais je jure que
c'est vrai ici c'est cyril et on dirait
que pour ceux qui sont fils unique et
inoubliable
incroyable et donc alors là c'est qui
yaël la science de gilles à la soeur de
cyril oui incroyable mais il est où elle
ajouté
voilà six mois c'était d'abord mise à
oui exactement photo en fait quoi ouais
je prenais sa photo le voit pas non mais
on voulait 6 mm
c'est le mien de serre il sait si rim
dont
tendon bât blesse au mapaq et médecins
mais ça si on m'avait dit que ça la
justice arrive ça allait faire bouffer
mais bien bien les vacances
sa sainteté derrick hall
qui moquent libère
[Applaudissements]
il n'y a jamais de hasard comme toi on
était vraiment proche vous avez vu bah
oui c'est vrai album et vous tu dis oui
évidemment nationale russie mais tu n'as
aucun mal à 12 ans elle en avait neuf
j'imagine
dernière j'étais déjà très maquillée
j'avais 11 ans dispensant la ba oui mais
vous c'est pas drôle vous êtes tout
baigné toute jeune à mathilde aussi mais
pas rester à dix bien dix jours
j'imaginais que j'adore cet achat c'est
qu'on cache bien la poitrine ouais ok je
ne voudrais pas montré grand-chose
opulente et comme vous trouvez cette
séquence très drôle mathieu moi j'ai
envie qu'on continue un peu à rigoler et
on a également une petite photo de vous
pour faire la voix après ça c'est génial
mais qui n'a pas beaucoup changé j'avais
dit à changer j'embauche septembre soit
très très bien vous n'êtes plus beau
maintenant je trouve mathieu c'est
gentil quel lèche cul des orties
non mais j'étais un peu maigrichon et
tout ça tu vois mais l'essai ya derrière
ce que je fais un bon burger
les soirées 1-1 et j'adore l'histoire
est absolument impérial j'avais une
belle manche j'avais 18 ans que j'avais
une belle monde pour mes distances et
piolenc route dans la poche et toula
arrête un petit bonjour